allez poursuite de notre débat avec
bruno belin qui est avec nous rappelle
que vous présidez le département de la
vienne on a parlé des grandes régions
on a parlé des communes mais les
départements dans tout ça est ce qu'ils
trouvent leur place est ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui trouvé peut-être une
nouvelle place dans cette organisation
territoriale pour dans la gestion des
dossiers agricoles est ce que vous
sentez à l'aise aujourd'hui face à ces
mastodontes pardon régionaux les
départements sont des collectivités
encore plus utile aujourd'hui
d'abord parce que la proximité notre
mode d'élection nous connecte au
territoire contrairement aux régions
mais je crois que le débat est ailleurs
vous avez 15 millions de français qui
vivent dans la ruralité et aujourd'hui
leurs questions c'est pas que font les
collectivités le millefeuille la loi
note c'est pas ça le débat s'est on a
envie de parler nous et on veut parler
de la ruralité et qu'on s'occupe de leur
réalité pas uniquement à chaque crise
agricole que ce que les élus peuvent
faire pour le monde rural
la 15 millions de français qui en ont
marre d'être abandonné alors c'est vrai
pour évidemment cette question de
l'agriculture qui est primordial ça je
crois qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde en a
conscience mais les mêmes questions sur
la nécessité de territoire franc ruraux
peut s'appliquer aussi sur le le
commerce de proximité
ce qu'on appelle des fois péjorativement
le petit commerce on en a besoin en
milieu rural
c'est exactement le même débat vous
savez chez nous jean pierre raffarin
s'est battu justement pour défendre ce
commerce de proximité par rapport aux
grandes surfaces
ça fait partie du débat qu'on a
aujourd'hui dans l'agriculture sur les
questions des prix les départements sont
utiles parce qu'ils peuvent aussi se
mobiliser nous avons lancé dans la
vienne au mois de septembre dernier des
états généraux de la ruralité
alors en quoi consistent ces nous
puissions faire 40
une quarantaine d'auditions nous avons
fait plus de 110 entendre tous les
messages de tous les acteurs du monde
rural
mais pour voir déboucher très vite c'est
à dire là à la rentrée prochaine à
l'automne prochain à l'occasion des des
congrès du congrès des départements de
france qui aura lieu à poitiers au
futuroscope déboucher sur des
propositions concrètes
on parle des circuits courts mais
comment est-ce qu'on voit bien que des
fois ça se bouscule avec le code des
marchés publics
on parle du acheter local comment on
peut être efficace comment on peut aussi
soutenir nos foires nos marchés voilà ça
c'est du concret et puis aussi les
questions du numérique parce que le
monde agricole a besoin des outils
innovants
donc on a besoin du numérique partout en
milieu rural donc là aussi ce sont les
départements qui ont pris la main parce
que cet aménagement du territoire
cette couverture du territoire ils y
sont complètement impliqué et puis voilà
il ya des questions de faire vivre nos
villages parce que faut soutenir les
questions de santé les questions
d'accessibilité
tout ça c'est lié la ruralité c'est un
ensemble
et cet ensemble a besoin de la
mobilisation des élus et de l' envie de
faire vivre par les élus alors vous
défendez bien j'allais dire ce
territoire départemental mais est ce que
vous n'avez pas l'impression quand même
qu'il y à des définitions de compétences
qui resteraient à préciser entre par
exemple les grandes régions et les
départements
aujourd'hui
nous élus ne pas tout faire tout nous
élus nous les connaissons nous
connaissons nos limites et nos
périmètres d'action mais ne perdons pas
d'énergie à expliquer ça aux acteurs et
ou à ceux qui en ont besoin sur les
territoires mobilisons nous utilisons
notre énergie à apporter des solutions
parfois des solutions nouvelles
quand le conseil général de la vienne
décide dans ces collèges dans ces ehpad
de jouer la carte locale quand nous
décidons avec notre collègue conseil
départemental des deux sèvres de créer
une marque poitou pour donner envie
d'acheter justement du local et bien
voilà ça c'est de la mobilisation c'est
de l'inventivité des élus et c'est autre
chose que ces questions de compétences
qui sont utiles nécessaires mais c'est
pas ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui
alors il y a une compétence majeure
fondamental pour les départements c'est
l'action sociale bien entendu pour les
personnes âgées la petite enfance etc
est ce que dans un département comme le
vôtre des agriculteurs
perçoivent par exemple le rsa ce fameux
rsa est ce que vous êtes amené à en
verser est-ce que des agriculteurs sont
confrontés également à ces phénomènes de
pauvreté
le département de la vienne est un petit
département 430 mille habitants environ
12000 allocataires du rsa est un peu
plus d'un millier d'allocataires sont
issus du monde agricole
donc voilà pour les chiffres bruts mais
au-delà de cette situation désespérante
bien évidemment ils demandent qu'à s'en
sortir aujourd'hui l'acteur agricole ne
demande pas de l'aide sociale ils
demandent surtout à avoir du chiffre
d'affaires c'est la question aujourd'hui
fondamental dans l'économie agricole
comment apporter du chiffre d'affaires
bruno belin comment faites-vous pour
intervenir éventuellement directement
pour aider des agriculteurs en
difficulté ou en détresse alors déjà
dans la vienne le conseil départemental
est toujours le premier partenaire de la
chambre d'agriculture oui mais très
concrètement nous devons être des ponts
des passerelles les deux dernières
manifestations de producteurs et
d'éleveurs je suis allé les rencontrer
notre responsabilité puisque nous avons
la chance d'être élu c'est d'être peu
avant tout leurs porte parole
notes après faible niveau des préfets
des services de l'état et donc nous
devons être forcément à leurs côtés moi
je suis complètement leur côté parce que
vous avez parlé de de colère de deux
salons crise c'est ça la désespérance si
nous ne faisons rien donc nous avons
cette obligation de mobilisation
générale pour être aux côtés de ceux qui
font vivre nos territoires
bruno belin cette agriculture qu'elles
soient locales régionales
départementales
c'est une formidable source d'identité
pour vos territoires n'est ce pas un
territoire comme le vôtre le département
de la vienne
eh bien peut s'identifier aussi à son
terroir et à ses productions agricoles
c'est vital
plusieurs fois ses revenus dans les
propos des invités l'agriculture
l'urgent pour l'agriculture c'est de
faire du chiffre d'affaires et donc de
produire
l'excellent normes je crois qu'il faut
vraiment insister là dessus
iny complètement l' envie d'agir donc il
ya une vraie question à se poser
aujourd'hui
quant aux normes compte sur toi là
transposition des normes et nous devons
nous élus locaux permettent justement
aux agriculteurs d'avoir de nouveaux
outils pour produire le département de
la vienne
un exemple parmi d'autres la nous
pouvons encore agir quelle que soit
l'évolution juste des lois département
de la vienne créer un un service un
petit service avec deux personnes qui
étaient déjà là qu'on met à disposition
du monde agricole pour faire digne
généré aider à monter des projets aider
à rechercher les financements européens
et autres voilà concrètement comment une
collectivité peut aider des exploitants
des éleveurs des exploitations à se
développer
bruno belin vous êtes optimiste ou
plutôt pessimiste sur l'avenir des
négociations à venir qui doivent
véritablement cette année avec l'europe
aujourd'hui un élu n'a jamais le droit
d'être pessimiste et ni désespéré alors
je sais pas si on est bon gérez-vous aux
mauvais élèves
moi j'ai fait le choix après 25
premières années passées en région
parisienne je fais le choix depuis 25
ans de travailler et de vivre en milieu
rural même dans ce qu'on appelle l'
hyper ruralité donc notre ambition elle
est surtout pour les territoires ruraux
d'être porteur d'espoir pour l'avenir